[Music]
who says Disney heroines only exist in
movies and TV shows there are actually
some Disney look-alikes who are walking
among us and they just so happen to be
some of the world's most beautiful
supermodels if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up because today we're
sharing 50 models who look exactly like
your favorite Disney heroines if we
didn't know any better we would
definitely think Snow White came to life
in the form of supermodel
kendall Jenner we never really noticed
the resemblance between the two of them
until we took a look at this side by
side comparison photo Kendall and Snow
White had the same dark hair the same
brown eyes and when Kendall rocks red
lipstick she's a dead ringer for the
Disney heroine if you think rouser
realized Cinderella and looks like it to
us the statuesque Beauty looks just like
everyone's favorite Disney Princess and
the similarities are jaw-dropping in
this photo Houston has the same wavy
hair same expressive eyes and the same
eyebrow shape as Cinderella she even has
her own real-life Prince her husband
Sonny James doesn't Victoria's Secret
model Lily Aldridge look exactly like
Pocahontas with their long dark hair
their olive skin and their big brown
eyes it's hard to tell these two apart
Lily and Pocahontas could definitely be
twin sisters if one of them wasn't drawn
by Disney animators of course in most
cases being compared to the Evil Queen
is no compliment but polish model
Patricia Garda Gallo is really giving
this evil villain a run for her money
the two of them look so much alike it's
almost as if Disney used Patricia's
features to create the queen of course
we know that's not the case but just
check out the uncanny resemblance they
have the same facial structure right
down to matching square jaw lines let's
just hope for Trisha won't be feeding
anyone a poisonous Apple any time soon
if you've ever wanted to see a real-life
Ariel we found the perfect doppelganger
The Little Mermaid star real-life twin
is none other than the German model
Barbra Maya
these two have way more in common than
just their flowing red hair
Aereo and Barbara each had beautiful
green eyes voluminous
eyelashes and the same megawatt smiles
all that Barbara is missing is a fork a
purple seashell bra and a mermaid tail
brush and model spatulas definitely has
a striking resemblance to Atlantis the
lost empires princess Kida ned acts the
warrior princess and sasha each have
hair so light it's almost white they
have the same pouty lips and check out
the almond shape of their eyes they're
practically identical don't you think
when frozen debuted every girl wanted to
be an ice princess by dressing up in
Elsa costumes but there's one person who
doesn't have to do much to look like
Elsa at all and that supermodel Candice
Swanepoel
from their long blonde hair to their
wide blue eyes and round faces Candice
and Elsa are definitely twinning no he
didn't fall down the rabbit hole you're
definitely looking at Alice in
Wonderland's real-life twin Swedish
model Elsa hosk this side-by-side photo
really shows just how much these two
favor each other and it has more to do
with just four golden blonde hair Elsa
and Alice each have white and expressive
eyes similar pouty lips and the same
base shape if Elsa were to wear a blue
dress with a white apron we definitely
wouldn't be able to tell these two apart
we can't help but notice the resemblance
between model Luanne and Disney heroine
move on the Chinese Beauty definitely
looks like she and Mulan was separated
at Birth just check out their jet-black
hair
similarly shaped eyes they're round
faces and their rosy cheeks it does me
decide to turn mulan into a live-action
film we should definitely play the role
of the heroine don't you agree
Spanish model Josephine scriber is a
beauty in her own right but she also
looks exactly like Sleeping Beauty's
Aurora we definitely did a double take
when we saw this photo of Josephine and
the Disney princess
they have the same long and wavy hair
almost identical brown eyes and even
their lips are pretty similar wouldn't
it be awesome to see Josephine play
Aurora in a sleeping beauty play let's
make it happen Disney Kim Kardashian may
think she's a real-life princess jasmine
but Indian model Bhoomi Kirara proves
that she's definitely the Disney
characters twins when you place blue
mica and Jasmine side-by-side you can
definitely see the similarities from
their golden skin to their wide eyes and
long brown hair someone please give
bhoomika crop top and some harem pants
so her transformation into Jasmine can
be complete doesn't it look like
Princess Tiana was brought to life in
the form of Engel and model Maria Borges
we sure think so
Maria's features are almost identical to
the New Orleans princess including her
gorgeous brown eyes and her wide sparkly
smile all Maria needs is her very own
Prince Naveen we were absolutely shocked
when we saw just how much supermodel
cara delevingne looks like Tinker Bell
while photographed wearing this green
dress it really brings out their
similarities even more Cara's hair is a
similar shade to Tinker Bell's and they
both have lovely blue eyes long
eyelashes and the same beautifully
shaped lips we would love to see Kara
dress up a sinker bell for Halloween we
think she definitely nail it this may
not be the first time you notice the
similarities between Lily Cole and
Merida of braids that's because the
Disney Princesses appearance was
actually inspired by the English super
model Disney animators took inspiration
from Lily's wild and untamed curls
sparkling blue eyes and her pouty lips
to create Merida
just give Lily some archery lessons and
she'll definitely become Merida's
real-life twin we never really noticed
the resemblance between Miranda Kerr and
Belle until we stumbled across this
photo of the supermodel and the Disney
princess
Miranda's yellow dress looks almost like
an exact replica of Belles ballgown
these two also had the same gorgeous
brown hair big brown eyes and even the
same smile when it comes to finding a
prince Miranda you look no further than
her fiance snapchat co-founder Evan
Spiegel were you shocked by these models
who look like real life Disney heroines
react in the comment section down below
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up
[Music]
you
[Music]